on ne peut pas proposer la mort on peut
laisser la mort intervenir évier
évidemment on peut l'accompagner autant
que faire se peut évidemment on peut la
soulager autant que faire se peut
évidemment mais elle reste elle sera
toujours quelque chose qui est un
événement qui nous surprend qui est plus
puissant que nous
l'euthanasie est
assistée ne sont pas me semble-t-il un
progrès 1 parce qu'effectivement tous
ceux qui sont en première ligne
les soignants les accompagnant les
malades les polyhandicapés sont contre
et considère que cette façon de mettre
en avant une dignité qui serait celle de
l'euthanasie s'oppose à toutes les
autres formes et de liberté et de
dignité
deuxièmement ce n'est pas un progrès
parce que bien évidemment à partir du
moment où vous mettez de la mort dans le
soin un des soins serait la mort vous
brouiller complètement la relation de
confiance qui existe entre les médecins
et les soigner troisièmement ce n'est
pas un progrès parce que tout le monde
sait bien les psychiatres l'expliquent
mais personne ne les en tant qu' il y a
toujours dans ces moments là à la fois
une volonté d'arrêter d'être soigné et
puis le besoin aussi d'avoir en face de
soi une forme de résistance qui
structure qui permet d'avancer de bien
comprendre ce qui se passe
voyez s'il n'y a plus de résistance à ce
moment là forcément il ya un effet
d'appel d'air quelque chose qui fait que
bombe très bien si vous le voulez si
c'est possible si ça rend dans le cadre
de la loi c'est une pas m'y opposer
si le fait de nous y opposer irait à
l'encontre de votre volonté à vos
patients
à ce moment là on rentre dans quelque
chose qui n'est plus un dialogue qui
n'est plus un accompagnement mais qui
est simplement une forme de distribution
de droits acquis que le médecin se doit
de donner au fur et à mesure que ces
droits sont demandés par par le patient
dernier point ce n'est pas un progrès
parce que là on franchit quand même
cette loi alors
appelons ça comme houellebecq
anthropologique de l'interdît de tuer de
quelque chose qui fait qu'on ne peut pas
proposer la mort on peut laisser la mort
intervenir et bien évidemment on peut
l'accompagner autant faire se peut
évidemment on peut la soulager autant
que faire se peut évidemment mais elle
reste elle sera toujours quelque chose
qui est un événement qui nous surprend
qui est plus puissant que nous et qui
fait que nous ne sommes pas maîtres de
la mort et que si nous la donne on est
bien quelque chose
d'autres une rupture puissante vient
saper tous les progrès que nous avons
réalisés jusqu'à présent
problème de cette loi de ce projet de
cette tunisie
plus au sud assister c'est exactement ce
que l'on voit en belgique en belgique
vous avez 1 50%
les d'asie qui ne sont pas déclarés 2
vous avez peu près 30% de ceux qui sont
au talent aziez et qui ont d'une façon
ou d'une autre un vice de consentement
ou un problème de consentement ou un
consentement mal éclairé et 3 la loi a
été étendue au profit de ceux qui ont
d'une façon ou d'une autre une
souffrance intolérable psychique
donc on a inclus dans les conditions
pour accéder à l'euthanasie la
souffrance psychique ce qui fait qu'on a
vu des jeunes de 24 ans 25 ans qui avait
des problèmes psychiques peu l'on peut
concevoir et qui donc ont été éligibles
entre guillemets à l'euthanasie ce qui a
mis en difficulté est en émoi la
communauté
les psychiatres partir du moment où on
légalise et bien à ce moment-là on croit
on a fait d exception d'euthanasie ou
qu'on ait fait cela pour des cas
particuliers et on voit la belgique ne
montre que effectivement il ya une forme
d'extension de plus en plus forte de
ceux qui y ont droit d'une part et
deuxièmement on fait sauter toutes les
protections que l'on croyait avoir mises
en oeuvre au début pour faire en sorte
que ça soit très encadrée